welcome to this video playing kill neon
mr. Cowell demora oh cool I've got a
50-percent school against my really had
our I always had rotted score but it's
fifteen percent now interesting so I'm
going with the Italian game yeah let's
just do something else for the sake of
variety can I go all night f1 no energy
for an idea let's play that first try to
delay castling a bit night over there
interesting maybe I should cast on now
let's cancel no it's almost symmetrical
but should be three shouldn't be a bad
idea okay just keep be five that's
interesting what to do it let's take it
and maybe d4 I am
so let's go a4 looks like a fairly why
it's playing that really quickly it said
such a normal position just interesting
so but what is this actually he's push
this pawns these pawns forward and they
look kind of weakish the a and B porn
here I wonder I mean look these seven is
not something that helps wire black very
much I think don't fear that Ruth
particularly ok so maybe up here we need
to is not making much sense to tonight a
form
ok
so where do I put my queen if the night
takes it to might have a good square and
ce4 in the future okay why not its trade
stuff I don't know what look actually
I thought so too i want to trade one
look or not it's an interesting question
maybe the other one now Kim maybe I
should have taken the other one
hmm
and the other one for Luke a for I would
have been better but yeah no use in
thinking about that now
not not so sure about all that I mean
structurally I'm better a 6b four e65
all that is potentially a bit weak but
terms of coordination it's not brilliant
my position maybe you should take play
93 or something but I have nights if
awesome I doubt that probably you should
go back
if he goes back with the hook up the f
39 f 1 93 oxy to challenge him on the C
file
my night is covering be to a five
everything so what is happening this
night is going where where exactly
don't get c5 from c5 I don't see where
it is going to a four
mmm one minute something
I can't read activate or not those nuts
to a tech stuff like be four or a six
it's a bit of a shame time morning what
a weird game I don't get it I have to be
better than the same game why am i worse
now let's go totally weird why did I
screw that up 30 strange and certainly
no way I'm worse in the end game at the
sound of that end game it's totally
impossible I can just take me three now
not sure what he's doing they're not
taking it again go h5 of course but ok
at the end I have nights it to where
that's much better of course the night
situ resource struggling here not seeing
that it's kind of embarrassing I mean
seeing it earlier I mean that's what I'm
trying to say
okay so is there some way to activate
not really I can go over there and then
other night is going to be active I have
no move that's a problem I really have
to move that little area is very stupid
but I couldn't really play something
good didn't see a good move I couldn't
move my nights and so on
check now so sorry I couldn't have to
take that of course okay white resign
that's a really that's that's an
impossible endgame I mean that's
impossible to lose how did I do that we
understand that that night on d3 is
active but I mean his bone structure
such such a wreck it's impossible to be
worse for wide huh the engine gives
equal may our cadets and some more can
understand but what did I do wrong what
exactly did I do wrong he I've already
clearly worse amazing okay that idea
nights you file a formal as some other I
didn't see any better move King everyone
is what the engine is giving it wants to
attack with King e to immediately maybe
that is really better so that after this
move I have plenty to is much better
a three look totally normal because you
want to move them the night from zg
three at some point but you don't have
the time so i have to do this what is
the engines line that just check that
this this check oops and then we're
going to basically repeat yeah that
looks that looks kind of okay so that
ended after have 3 i'm really already in
some trouble it really it's really
difficult now that that stuff that's
that's not a good position i cannot move
my nights now i have our own behalf okay
a million now no the engine is again
giving me on why didn't I go h4 right
stupid ok anyway g5 it says it's a
tricky position nitey one is better now
as sorting sticks and night c4 is better
you cannot take be three of course yes
when he's tied tied up a little bit him
that's actually pretty easy draw now
because he doesn't have anything you can
move this king only I cannot move his
nights okay yeah so it took chaps I'm
some stupid moves to really lose that
game check that's weird I did not see
that that's strange I mean I saw that
King I really didn't see for some reason
I'd c4 I will I always thought I have to
like cover that but it's not the case i
can just do this yeah pretty stupid loss
really okay well
thanks for watching